bruno retailleau le président des
sénateurs les républicains et candidat
aux régionales dans les pays-de-la-loire
et l'invité de preuves par 3 bonsoir
bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous pour
ce rendez-vous de public sénat avec l'
agence france presse et vous répondrai
au cours de cette émission divisé en 3
donc à trois grandes questions d'abord
est ce que vous êtes choqués par les
arrestations à air france et le procès
qui s'annonce pour cinq salariés
deuxième question que vous posera tout à
l'heure nadège pull jack la primaire de
la droite et du centre est elle menacée
après les réserves de nicolas sarkozy
que vous avez d'ailleurs rencontré ce
matin et qui émet des doutes sur la
possibilité de mettre en place dix mille
bureaux de vote enfin le troisième
question tout à l'heure avec perrine
tarneaud françois hollande at il répondu
à votre lettre du week-end sur
l'évacuation des opposants au projet
d'aéroport à notre dame des landes vous
vous dénoncez une république qui est
incapable de se défendre vous nous direz
donc si votre missive est votre colère
ont obtenu une réponse de la part du
chef de l'état d'abord bruno retailleau
la polémique qui sont venus mme sur les
restes d'arrestation air france après
des violences contre deux membres de la
direction bien sûr les images choquantes
ont fait le tour du monde proprement
scandaleux dit la cgt et la gauche de la
gauche à propos de ces arrestations et
puis des jugements qui sont annoncées ce
procès de cinq salariés pour violences
aggravées alors vous est ce que vous
êtes choqués par ces gardes à vue ces
arrestations ce procès absolument pas
tout simplement parce que je considère
que force doit rester à la loi y'a
aucune catégorie de français qui doivent
se sentir au dessus de la loi
depuis quand des syndicalistes parce
qu'ils sont syndicalistes pourraient
avoir recours à la violence et ne pas
être sanctionné par la loi personne ne
le comprendrait je pense que la violence
n'est pas admissible dans un pays
civilisé comme la france on peut
parfaitement manifester on peut
parfaitement faire savoir sa
désapprobation sur des points qui
peuvent concerner un plan notamment sur
la vie de air france mais la violence
est absolument inadmissible que vous
êtes choqué alors par certaines
déclarations polies l'injure à nier mais
bien sûr monsieur mélenchon un jour de
deuil pour la france il se regarde dans
la glace 30 man franchement un leader
politique t'aurais savoir que la loi
s'applique à tous et la définition de la
république je l' ai connu parfois
beaucoup plus sûrs si yu alors que les
coliques 1 quand on écoute le secrétaire
général de la cgt numéro un du syndicat
philippe martinez qui lit et lui le
geste il parle de la chemise déchirée et
aussi le début d'un lynchage auquel on a
assisté le geste est là est à la hauteur
de la violence sociale du plan de
suppressions d'emplois non il mais c'est
donc dans la balance non non il peut pas
y avoir d'excusés à la violence la
violence doit être réprimée d'où
qu'elles viennent quelle qu'elle soit
peu importe qu'elles viennent demain
d'un patron aujourd'hui des
syndicalistes après demain de je ne sais
quelle catégorie sociale il n'y a pas de
catégories sociales y compris les élus
qui doivent se sentir de la justice de
la loi doit passer à dire que c'est un
genre il doit être la même pour tous et
ses salariés la définition de l'état de
droit ces dernières risquent une peine
de trois ans de prison ça vous paraît
légitime trois ans coûtaient je m'en
remettrai à la f6 de mon pays points
d'accord tant que vous avez les mêmes
mots que manuel valls finalement reid
avait d'abord dénoncé les voyous à air
france et puis à ryad il a expliqué
qu'il ne fallait pas chercher d'excusés
à la violence et qu'il ne fallait pas
l'opposé à la violence sociale
d'ailleurs il a raison bah écoutez on
peut partager on n'est pas en guerre
civile on peut pas rêver sur le plan des
principes en tout cas républicain on
peut partager la même fermeté simplement
j'observe on pourra en parler dans
quelques instants mais j'observe que la
fermeté de monsieur valls elle est à
géométrie variable bah oui regardez on
en paie dizaine de personnes sur l'a1
ont bloqué pendant des heures et des
heures voilà pour faire sortir de prison
une deux personnes et pendant ce temps
là il les automobilistes sur l'autoroute
plus fréquentée de france qui ont été
bloqués ça ça n'est pas normal qu'est ce
qu'a fait monsieur valls à ce moment là
là aussi il doit pas y avoir deux poids
deux mesures françois hollande était sur
vos terres aujourd'hui enfin dans votre
région à saint nazaire il a rendu visite
aux chantiers navals stx
quand un carnet de commandes
formidablement remplir pour les
étudiants mais notre bilan de football a
ajouté le chef de l'état il est
interpellé par des syndicalistes et il a
défendu la nécessité du dialogue social
là aussi bien sûr voulu donner
parfaitement raison bruno retailleau
l'actualité c'est aussi le lancement du
débat sur le but 2016 c'est à dire ce
sera le dernier en année pleine un du
quinquennat du chef de l'état l'heure
des baisses d'impôts se félicite le
ministre des finances michel sapin on
écoute la baisse des impôts en faveur
des entreprises pour leur permettre
d'investir et d'embaucher la baisse des
impôts en faveur des ménages oui 12
millions de ménages français sur 10 7
millions qui aujourd'hui paient l'impôt
sur le revenu vont bénéficier d'une
baisse de leur impôt sur le revenu et
qu'on ne vienne pas me dire qu'il ne
s'agit pas là des classes moyennes c'est
le coeur des classes moyennes de celle à
qui nous avons demandé un effort mais
auquel il est légitime aujourd'hui de
rendre une partie de cet effort parce
que l'effort était nécessaire mais
aujourd'hui la justice fiscale est
indispensable le chiffre augmente
apparemment remettant en parle de 12
millions de foyers c'est vraiment parler
de 9 jusqu'à présent mais est ce quand
même est-ce que vous reconnaissez que
dans ce budget quand même il y a une
bonne nouvelle pour les contribuables
non je vais vous expliquer les deux
raisons pour lesquelles ce que dit
monsieur sapin c'est au mieux de
l'humour au pire du cynisme premier
élément depuis le début du quinquennat
l'augmentation du produit de l'impôt sur
le revenu a augmenté de 20 milliards il
est passé de 50 milliards à 70 milliards
et en même temps la base sur laquelle
s'applique cet impôt est passé 5 un peu
plus de 50% des français à 46% faut pas
être sortis des grandes écoles de
mathématiques pour voir que ce sont
toujours moins de français qui fait
paraît toujours plus à l'est deuxième
exemple pour un certain nombre de
familles avec les réformes du quotient
familial eh bien ces familles notamment
qui ont plusieurs enfants d'une famille
aussi nombreuses et bien on vu log alors
leur peau augmenté depuis le ministre
dit qu'une page est en train de se
tourner un film en l'île maurice oui en
tout cas il ne dit pas la vérité
les chiffres que je vous donne oui bien
sûr et quand un certain nombre de deux
contribuables français ont constaté que
l'impôt foncier vous savez sur des zones
tendues a à peu près 28 grandes
agglomérations en france ont pu
augmenter multiplié par 3 par cinq voire
jusqu'à multiplier par 50 vous trouvez
que ça valait réjouir et vous pensez que
les propos de monsieur sapin pour les
couvre les convaincre non ski ski les
convaincre et c'est que les impôts
baissent réellement or les impôts on ne
baisse pas en france et d'ailleurs on a
on est le pays qui est le champion du
monde de la dépense publique 57% avec la
finlande mais c'est exorbitant par
rapport à beaucoup d'autres milliards
d'euros d'économies vous les avez
déniché vous attendait des explications
écoutez c'est pas moi qui le dit c'est
valérie rabault qui valait encore
socialiste lé rapporteur général du
budget elle n'est pas de ma famille
politique et comme vous l'avez dit
socialiste s'est dit vraiment oui il
doit y avoir un loup pas trop léger
comme ici il aura toutes les
informations et tous tes confirmation
non mais écoutez je vais vous dire très
simplement il n'y a pas de baisse de
suite contrairement à ce qui s'est passé
en allemagne contrairement à ce qui
s'est passé dans beaucoup d'autres
grands pays en 2017 on à ce programme
d'économies de 50 milliards soit disant
eh bien en 2017 y aura plus de 60
milliards de dépenses publiques donc où
est la baisse il n'y a pas de baisse il
ya effectivement une décélération
ça augmente ma vie valeo perd alors vous
entendu selon vos pas de baisses
d'impôts pas de baisse des dépenses
publiques et une question se pose
concernant les impôts bruno retailleau
elle est dans l'air d'ailleurs elle est
relancé par jean marc ayrault l'ancien
premier ministre est ce qu'il faut
fusionner selon vous l'impôt sur le
revenu et la csg l'ancien premier
ministre est soutenu par 130 députés ps
ben oui c'est jean marc ayrault le
frondeur marc ayrault le fondeur
d'ailleurs vous avez le gouvernement
beaucoup de mal ils vont essayer
d'évacuer son amendement sur le plfss
fin sur n'importe sur la loi de
financement de la sécurité sociale non
je moi j'y suis opposée tout simplement
parce que ce serait encore plus impôts
pour une moitié de français puisqu'il ya
un impôt qui est
progressif c'est la csg et l'autre qui
vont proportionnelle vous additionnez
les deux vous ajoutez les deux et ça
fait un cocktail chimique explosif avec
de très fortes hausses d'impôts pour
environ 40 45 % de français alors vous
l'avez constaté l'exécutif le chef de
l'état et le premier ministre est très
mobilisée par la situation
internationale est ce que vous avez
d'ailleurs relevé la dimension
présidentielle du déplacement du premier
ministre au proche-orient puisqu'on l'a
vu en egypte en jordanie en arabie
saoudite
va coûter 2 ça me choque pas franchement
tous les premiers ministres sur tous les
gouvernements sous tous les prisons de
la république font des voyages à chaque
fois ces voyages sont calibrés avec le
quai d'orsay la cellule diplomatique à
la fois de matignon et de l'elysée donc
je ne vais pas ajouté lapierre le manuel
valls est une où je trouve franchement
on peut faire des polémiques qui soit
vraie polémique celle ci n en vous par
alors le chef le chef du gouvernement a
évoqué les raids français sur la syrie
qui ont fait des victimes on l'a appris
parmi les djihadistes parti de france
peut être 6 on écoute manuel valls les
attentats ont déjà eu lieu il des morts
compatriotes qui ont été tuées par des
terroristes
partir du moment où nous savons que ces
attentats les attentats se prépare ici
en syrie au nom de la légitime défense
c'est une obligation que de frapper nous
continueront quelles que soient les
nationalités les terroristes de ce
produit là
vous êtes d'accord évidemment le
terrorisme n'a pas de passeport bruno
retailleau la terroriste n'a pas de
passeport mais là je suis désolé là je
vais critiquer la position diplomatique
de la france parce que on retrouve dans
la position diplomatique de la france
les coûts de yoyo de françois hollande
vous souvenez quand ils voulaient faire
des frappes punitives sur
damas et à l'époque quand les etats unis
se prononcer on a fait un virage sur
l'aide ensuite il ya quelques mois
françois hollande nous disait faut
surtout pas faire des frappes aériennes
sur la syrie il ya quelques semaines
le premier ministre le ministre
songèrent sont venus à l'assemblée et au
sénat pour dire maintenant faut frapper
d'énormes au nom de la légitime défense
mais quelle la légitime défense et de la
prévention écouter le terrorisme la
frappe il allait coûter le terrorisme il
a frappé au moins de janvier bien et moi
je pense que la politique c'est d'abord
s'attaquer aux causes afin de soigner
les conséquences s'attaquer aux causes
c'est quoi c'est détruire éradiquer dash
éradiquer d'âge ça veut dire quoi ça
veut dire frappé des slaouis dahesh en
irak et ancien emploi les militaires
français alors oui mais alors avec un
retournement puisque ce sont des toutes
premières frappes valorisé avec une
forme de scénographie de communication a
pris j'ose dire bien sûr communication
politique ce que je veux dire c'est que
malheureusement un message adressé aux
jeunes français qui seraient tentés de
partir aussi
je vais vous dire comment peut-on
détruire d'atg on ne détruira pas des ch
j'y suis allé je veux dire en août 2014
on ne détruira pas dahesh avec des
frappes aériennes plus personne ne le
croit au fait qu'on lui en sort
justement le plan je ne fais ni
confiance aux russes ni aux américains
je pense que la france elle est ce pays
dans le monde dont la voix est écoutée
hors jeu malheureusement et françois
hollande cette voie elle ne porte plus
que j'attends de la vacance c'est que la
france organise avec les russes avec
l'iran avec les puissances régionales la
turquie qui reste à convaincre qui étant
un état dans l'es8 et terrible je pense
qu'il faudra intervenir au sol pas nous
seulement accord mais si on n'intervient
pas au sol on ne peut pas viendra pas à
éradiquer le terrorisme d'âge et on ne
parviendra pas à arrêter le flot de
réfugiés pardon de dire ça oui je sais
que c'est un peu politiquement incorrect
mais c'est la vérité qu'est-ce que
politiquement incorrect en fait de dire
qu'il faut frapper au sol d'accord
les armes et régionales agissent
simplement j'ai ma question sur la rue
600 personnes et fait ses larmes c'est
ce sont les aviez les avions russes qui
aujourd'hui des blés un peu le terrain
pour pour l'armée de bachar el-assad est
ce que ça c'est une bonne démarche que
vous soutenez moi je soutiens d'abord je
tiens mon pays m'a évidemment je suis
français parlementaires français je suis
patriote
simplement il faut qu'on arrête avec la
russophobie on a besoin de l'iran on a
besoin de la russie pour vaincre des
scouts et ce n'est pas moi qui l'ait dit
vous savez très bien pendant la deuxième
guerre mondiale il a fallu tendre la
main staline je suis désolé c'est aller
c'est être tout autre chose que bachar
al assad et surtout monsieur poutine
pour vaincre la main dans la main non
non c'est pas je pars dit simplement je
dis organisons une grande qu acteur
international avec des troupes au sol
qui ne seront pas prioritairement
occidentales parce que je veux vraiment
mais par majorité certains dans votre
camp ont dit qu'il fallait vous allez
vous arrêter français oui je suis désolé
en irak vous allez les forces spéciales
oui évidemment est ce que vous imaginez
qu'on peut frapper avec des accents
relais au sol sans relais mais surtout
nous on est donc donc il faut l'assumer
il a envoyé des militaires françaises
que ce que je prenne enrayée je vais
vous dire ce que je crains c'est que
death est en train de s'enraciner je
pense que la syrie coagule énormément je
veux dire aujourd'hui de frappe
évidemment et on oublie un peu l'irak
moi je pense qu'on devrait libérer la
plaine de ninive libéré mossoul et
ensuite prendre en tenaille entre damas
et puis l'irak les les forces
terroristes évidemment et ça permettrait
d'arrêter de stopper le flot des
réfugiés mais pour être parfaitement
clair vous êtes favorable à l'envoi de
militaires français au sol en série et
on n'est pas dans n'importe quelle
condition encore une fois de face dans
n'importe quelle nation minoritaire sur
ces moments bien oui on est déjà au sol
on est déjà au sol oui mais ce que je
veux c'est que mon pays
réalise 7 travail en tout cas cette
coalition internationale vous m'avez pas
vraiment répondu sur le petit extrait
convient d'entendre
qui parlait dé des frappes contre les
djihadistes les frappes notamment contre
les français est-ce qu'il faut accentuer
si on a tué six français 1 qui sont
partis faire le djihad là bas est-ce
qu'il faut accentuer ce qui pourrait
ressembler à une politique d'élimination
cibler non mais ces deux français et
bien sûr oui il faut détruire oui pas de
france 29 lancers lampard des
terroristes on va pas leur demander
d'écrire suivre une formation pour
revenir dans votre pays d'écouté bien
sûr tous les terroristes quelle que soit
leur nationalité simplement ce que je
vous dis c'est que tant qu'on détruit
padash on en tue six terroristes et puis
on a 20 30 40 cents 200 milles qui
arrivent de toute l'europe du monde
entier voilà aujourd'hui ce qui s'est
passé on a détruit des forces d'âge
elles se sont reconstitués exactement
comme si on n'avait rien fait
c'est ce qu'il a été trop discret
aujourd'hui en signant pour dix
milliards d'euros de contrats en arabie
saoudite est ce qu il était trop discret
en n'évoquant pas publiquement les
droits de l'homme dans un pays qui
pratique on le sait la peine de mort à
grande échelle et qui menace qui a
condamné on le rappelle à la
décapitation un jeune opposant chiite
mike l'abolition je pense que le
wahhabisme
a fait beaucoup pour
la radicalisation de l'islamisme dans le
monde
ryad de ce point de vue là a une
responsabilité éminente il faut être
capable de le dire simplement je serait
incohérent avec ce que je vous dis ce
que je viens de vous dire je pense que
la politique étrangère c'est